This Mother's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. That's right. Mother's Day is almost here. It is Sunday, May 11th. Wow, that just really snuck up on me. It's like all of a sudden it's here. What are your plans? Well, I'm taking my mom to New York
今年母亲节，就让梅西百货来指导你挑选礼物吧。没错。母亲节快到了。就在5月11日，星期日。哇，时间过得太快了，不知不觉就到了。你有什么计划吗？嗯，我要带我妈妈去纽约
for a little Mother's Day celebration. How fun. Pre-Mother's Day, yes. She has always wanted to visit Ellis Island to see her grandmother's name on the log there. That is gonna be so moving. I know, it was one of her bucket list items in life and this year I'm making it happen.
庆祝一下母亲节。太棒了。母亲节前夕，是的。她一直想去埃利斯岛看看她祖母的名字是否刻在那里的名册上。那一定非常感人。我知道，这是她人生愿望清单上的一项，今年我要帮她实现。
Oh man, I love that. Well, you know, we usually take my mom out to lunch for Mother's Day, my sisters, you know, they all live near her. And this year I'm actually gonna be traveling to see her just a few weeks after Mother's Day. So I'm gonna to miss that lunch, but we have a FaceTime hangout planned so I can sort of be with them. Oh, I love that. A virtual hangout. Yeah. Well, Lee asked me what I might like to do to celebrate Mother's Day. And I said I want a fancy tea.
哦，天哪，我太喜欢这个了。嗯，你知道的，我们通常会带我妈妈出去吃午饭来庆祝母亲节，我的姐妹们，你知道的，她们都住在她附近。今年其实我会在母亲节后几周才去旅行看望她。所以我会错过那顿午饭，不过我们计划了一次FaceTime连线，这样我就能好像和她们在一起了。哦，我太喜欢这个了。虚拟聚会。是的。嗯，李问我母亲节想做点什么来庆祝。我说我想去吃高级下午茶。
I love a fancy tea. Now that I can eat gluten again, it's like literally the first thing I wanted. Because I did not miss much being gluten-free. I was fine giving up pasta and I was even okay giving up a lot of bread. Yeah. But I really missed being able to do a high tea. I mean, high tea is all gluten, basically. It's so fun though. So I'm having high gluten for Mother's Day.
我太喜欢高级下午茶了。现在我又能吃面食了，这简直是我最想要的第一件事。因为我不吃麸质的时候其实也没错过太多。我放弃意面没问题，甚至放弃很多面包也觉得还好。是的。但我真的很怀念能去喝英式下午茶。我的意思是，英式下午茶基本上全都是面食。不过真的很有趣。所以我母亲节要大吃特吃含面食的下午茶。
What about you? Do you have plans? Well, you know, the last few years, me and my tennis scouts do a Mother's Day doubles little tournament. Oh, yes, I knew this. Isn't that so fun? Yes. And then we have brunch right after everyone brings something.
你呢？你有什么计划吗？嗯，你知道的，过去几年里，我和我的网球球友们会举办一个母亲节双打小型锦标赛。哦，对，我知道这个。是不是很有趣？是的。然后比赛一结束我们就会吃早午餐，每个人都会带点东西来。
And then in the afternoon, I spend that time with Josh and the kids and I love to garden. We usually have a huge dinner. Josh makes a big dinner and he always gets me a plant because I love plants. And then him and the kids usually pick out one gift that I don't know what it's going to be. Just like a little surprise. They're really sweet about it. The kids all make me cards.
然后在下午，我会和乔希以及孩子们一起度过，我非常喜欢园艺。我们通常会吃一顿丰盛的晚餐。乔希会做一大桌晚餐，而且他总是会送我一盆植物，因为我太喜欢植物了。接着他和孩子们通常会挑出一件我不知道是什么的礼物。就当是个小惊喜。他们在这方面真的很贴心。孩子们都给我亲手做了卡片。
And this year, Josh was like, do you have your eye on anything? And I said, actually, I would love some perfume. I'm like out. I have like these little tester tubes. I'm weirdly into perfume all of a sudden now again too. Yeah. What's that about? I love a scent.
今年，乔希问我，你有没有看中什么东西？我说，其实我很想要一些香水。我的用完了。我只有这些小试管样品。不知怎么的，最近我又突然对香水感兴趣了。是的。这是怎么回事？我很喜欢气味。
I don't know. Maybe it's ladies of a certain season. I don't know. But I love Jo Malone and Macy's carries Jo Malone. And sometimes they do like a fun bundle where you get the little perfume and a candle. Oh. Yeah.
我不知道。也许是因为到了某个特定的年纪吧。我不知道。但我很喜欢祖马珑，而梅西百货就有卖祖马珑。有时他们还会推出一些有趣的套装，里面既有小瓶香水又有蜡烛。哦。是的。
That's very nice. Well, Lee also asked me what I wanted as a gift this year. He actually bought me a couple books and I accidentally opened the package when it arrived. So I spoiled that one and I couldn't think of anything I wanted. So I went to the Macy's Mother's Day gift guide. It's so great. It is. And they have a tab called Lux Gifts.
那太好了。嗯，李也问我今年想要什么礼物。他其实给我买了几本书，结果快递到的时候我不小心把包裹打开了。所以我把那个惊喜剧透了，而且我想不出自己还想要什么。于是我浏览了梅西百货的母亲节送礼指南。太棒了。确实如此。他们有一个叫做“奢华礼物”的标签页。
And I was like, tell me more. I might like a Lux gift. So I was scrolling through and I found this really cute gold tone stainless steel bracelet watch from Coach. It has like little blue flowers on the face. Here, let me show you. I just kind of fell in love with it. Oh, you have a picture? Look at that. That is so like cute. On the face. Here, let me show you. I just kind of fell in love with it. Oh, you have a picture?
当时我就想，快跟我说说。我可能会喜欢一件奢华礼物。于是我往下浏览，发现了这款非常可爱的蔻驰金色不锈钢手链表。表盘上还有小小的蓝色花朵。给你，我拿给你看看。我简直对它爱不释手。哦，你有照片吗？看那个。那个真的好可爱。表盘上。给你，我拿给你看看。我简直对它爱不释手。哦，你有照片吗？
Look at that. That is so like cute and dainty. That's what I got. So I sent Lee the link and I hope I get it. Well, you know, Macy's is having a sale right now with 25% off Mother's Day gifts. Oh, I know, I told Lee you can get 25% off this watch. Did you send Josh the perfume link?
快看那个。真的好可爱好精致。这就是我买的。所以我把链接发给了李，希望我能收到它。嗯，你知道的，梅西百货现在正在举办特卖活动，母亲节礼品享75折优惠。哦，我知道，我告诉过李你可以用75折买到这款手表。你把香水的链接发给乔希了吗？
I did. And you know, what I also love about Macy's Mother's Day gift guide is there are sections. You can do $25, $50. Like there's so many options. I know. I hope I get my perfume. I love it.
发了。你知道的，梅西百货母亲节送礼指南最吸引我的地方在于它有不同的分类。你可以按25美元、50美元来挑选。选择真的太多了。我知道。我希望我能收到我的香水。我太喜欢了。
Save an extra 25% off on gifts for mom this Mother's Day. Shop the Mother's Day gift guide now at macy's.com slash gift guide. Sale runs May 6th through 11th. From early morning workouts that need a boost to late night drives that need vibes, a good playlist can help you make the most out of your everyday.
在这个母亲节，购买妈妈的礼物可额外享受75折优惠。立即访问 macy's.com/giftguide 选购母亲节送礼指南。特卖活动从5月6日持续到11日。从需要注入活力的清晨锻炼，到需要氛围感的深夜驾车，一份好歌单能帮你充分利用每一天。
And when it comes to everyday spending, you can count on the PC Insider's World Elite Mastercard to help you earn the most PC optimum points everywhere you shop. With the best playlists, you never miss a good song. With this card, you never miss out on getting the most points on everyday purchases. The PC Insider's World's Elite MasterCard,
说到日常消费，你可以信赖PC Insider's World Elite万事达卡，它能帮你你在每一个购物场所赚取最多的PC optimum积分。有了最好的歌单，你绝不会错过一首好歌。有了这张卡，你在日常消费中也绝不会错过赚取最多积分的机会。PC Insider's World's Elite万事达卡，
the card for living unlimited. Conditions apply to all benefits. Visit pcfinancial.ca for details. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories.
一张开启无限生活的信用卡。所有优惠均受条件限制。详情请访问 pcfinancial.ca。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节以及大量VFF的故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。
We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello everyone. Hi. Welcome to Office Ladies 6. Hi. Welcome to Office Ladies 6.0. We have a great guest joining us today. This is one of our most requested guests. And we have been trying so long.
我们是《办公室女士》6.0版。大家好。嗨。欢迎来到《办公室女士》6。嗨。欢迎来到《办公室女士》6.0版。今天有一位重磅嘉宾加入我们。这是我们呼声最高的一位嘉宾之一。我们已经邀请了很久了。
There's been lots of scheduling things and it finally happened. Today we are going to be speaking with Lindsay Broad, who played Kathy Sims, and she's going to talk all about her time on the show. Well, you know, Lindsay joined the show in season eight. She was in a total of 12 episodes, and we all know how much everyone loves Jim and Pam. So the character of Cathy really made some people prickle. But I found an article on Collider Lady
中间有很多档期问题，不过最终还是成了。今天我们将与饰演凯茜·西姆斯的琳赛·布罗德进行对话，她将畅谈她在剧中的经历。嗯，你知道的，琳赛是在第八季加入剧组的。她总共出演了12集，我们都知道大家都多么喜爱吉姆和帕姆。所以凯茜这个角色确实让一些人感到芒刺在背。但我曾在Collider网站上看到过一篇文章
that gave a different perspective on the role of Kathy and what she gave to the show. Oh, I would love to hear that. It said, Kathy might have gotten between Jim and Pam, but she's a great character because she brings out the best in everyone. We get to see just how loyal Jim is. The honeymoon stage for Jim and Pam is long over, and the two are now busy every day with kids, yet Jim never wavers once.
它对凯茜这个角色以及她对节目的贡献给出了不同的视角。哦，我很想听听看。上面说，凯茜可能介入了吉姆和帕姆之间，但她是个很棒的角色，因为她激发了每个人最好的一面。我们得以看到吉姆有多么忠诚。吉姆和帕姆的蜜月期早已结束，两人现在每天都忙着照顾孩子，然而吉姆却从未动摇过一次。
And then there's Dwight, who saves Jim without even intending to. When Dwight comes into the room and sees a half-dressed Cathy with Jim, he doesn't pause or doubt his friend. He knows Jim would never cheat on Pam, so it doesn't even cross his mind. Bed bugs are truly the only thing he cared about. And a couple of deleted scenes would have revealed even more. One has Pam talking to Jim on the phone at the hotel.
还有德怀特，他甚至在无意中拯救了吉姆。当德怀特走进房间，看到半穿着衣服的凯茜和吉姆在一起时，他没有停顿，也没有怀疑他的朋友。他知道吉姆绝对不会对不起帕姆，所以他根本没往那方面想。臭虫真的是他唯一关心的事情。如果有几个被删减的片段，还会揭示更多内容。其中一个片段是帕姆在酒店里给吉姆打电话。
Yes, we talk about this in our interview with Lindsay. We sure do. He tells his wife everything, but rather than being angry, Pam is amused. Mm-hmm. So, Kathy's character once again is used to show how strong Jim and Pam's relationship really is. Well, I wish more people would have had that in mind when they were watching the show, because as we talk about with Lindsay, man, there were some rough patches of fans
是的，我们在对琳赛的采访中谈到了这一点。我们确实聊了。他对妻子无话不说，但帕姆非但没有生气，反而觉得很有趣。嗯哼。所以，凯茜这个角色再次被用来展现吉姆和帕姆的关系究竟有多么牢固。嗯，我希望大家在看剧时能多想想这一点，因为正如我们和琳赛聊到的那样，天哪，当时有些粉丝的反应相当激烈
really coming for her. Yeah, even the week we interviewed her, she posted on her Instagram a screen grab of a comment someone made where they don't like Cathy. They think it's her. I know, I know. So still to this day, she gets it. Well, I ran into Lindsay recently in New York.
甚至可以说是疯狂攻击她。对啊，就在我们采访她的那一周，她在Instagram上发了一张截图，上面是某个不喜欢凯茜的网友留下的评论。他们觉得她就是那样的人。我懂，我懂。所以直到今天，她还在承受这些。对了，我最近在纽约偶遇了琳赛。
We ended up in the same audience of the same play. I know. And we talk about that in our interview. And what it made me realize, Angela, is that I have not shared my big news with everybody. That I am going to be doing a play. Oh my gosh. I can't believe we haven't talked about this. We have not talked about this. You shared, I think, on Instagram, right?
我们居然在同一场戏剧的观众席里碰到了。真的。我们在采访中也聊到了这个。安吉拉，这让我意识到，我还没有把我的大好消息告诉大家。我要去演一部舞台剧了。哦，天哪。真不敢相信我们还没聊过这个。我们确实没聊过。我想你是在Instagram上分享的吧？
I shared on Instagram. But we haven't chatted about it. Here, this is huge news in the life and life goals of Janet Fisher. Yes, and of Lee Kirk. Oh yes, of course. This is my second project that I am doing, thanks to Lee Kirk and his amazing writing.
我在Instagram上分享过。但我们还没好好聊过。听着，这可是珍娜·费舍尔人生和人生目标中的一件大事。是的，也是李·柯克的。哦，对，当然。这是我做的第二个项目，这要归功于李·柯克和他出色的剧本。
This fall, I am gonna be starring in a play called Ashland Avenue, written by Lee Kirk. It's going to be at the Goodman Theater in Chicago. I mean, that's a big deal. The Goodman Theater. That is a big, big deal. It is their 100th anniversary year. It's their centennial year.
今年秋天，我将主演一部名为《阿什兰大道》的戏剧，由李·柯克编剧。它将在芝加哥的古德曼剧院上演。我的天，这可是件大事。古德曼剧院。这绝对是一件非常、非常大的事。今年正好是他们建院100周年。是他们的百年庆典年。
We are kicking off their centennial year with this play. That's so great! So please come see me. Preview starts September 6th and then the play officially opens on September 15th. I will share all of that. I am coming. I can't wait to come and see you on stage lady. I can't wait. I know how much you love the theater and being part of that community. I've gotten to see you on stage twice. One in reasons to be happy and the second one was meteor shower. One was in New York. One was in San Diego. Now I'm going to see you in Chicago. Lady, you could have a little map with all the little dots of the different theaters you've been
我们将用这部剧为他们的百年庆典拉开序幕。太棒了！所以请一定要来看我演出。预演将于9月6日开始，然后该剧将于9月15日正式开幕。我会把所有这些信息都分享出来的。我一定去。等不及要去看你在舞台上的表演了，亲爱的。我迫不及待了。我知道你有多么热爱戏剧以及成为那个社区的一部分。我有幸看过两次你在舞台上的演出。一次是《重归美好的理由》，第二次是《流星雨》。一次在纽约。一次在圣迭戈。现在我要去芝加哥看你了。亲爱的，你简直可以弄张地图，上面标满你去过的不同剧院的小红点啦
in. That would be so fun. I have a request. What? Well then, will you do a play in London that I can come to? Oh, in the West End? Yes. Yes. Okay, let's put that out there. Okay, please, please.
在。那太有趣了。我有个请求。什么？那你会不会去伦敦演一部我可以去看的话剧？哦，在西区？嗯。好，那就这么说定了。好，拜托拜托。
Well, it's very exciting. Very exciting. I got offered a play in Dublin. And I couldn't do it. I know you could have come visited me in Dublin. That would have been amazing! I know it was a really good play, too, but it just didn't work out in my life, but, um... Well, as our new season and new chapters of our life begin,
这太令人兴奋了。太兴奋了。我接到了一部在都柏林演出的话剧邀请。但我去不了。我知道你本来可以去都柏林看我的。那太棒了！我知道那也是部非常好的话剧，但我的生活里实在抽不出时间，不过……好吧，随着我们的新一季和生活的新篇章开始，
I will follow you around and go to all of your theater performances. It's all I want to do now, truly. Well, this play, Ashland Avenue, it is funny, and it'll also just break your heart in a million pieces. It's a beautiful, beautiful... It's a work of art, and it'll also just break your heart in a million pieces. It's a beautiful, beautiful, it's a work of art. And I can't wait. Lee is such a good writer.
我会跟着你到处跑，去看你的每一场戏剧演出。这也是我现在唯一想做的事，真的。好吧，这部话剧《阿什兰大道》，它既搞笑，又会让你心碎成千上万片。这是一部美丽至极的……这是一件艺术品，它也同样会让你心碎成千上万片。这是一部美丽至极的艺术品。我已经迫不及待了。李真是一位优秀的作家。
Yeah, it's got an amazing cast of local Chicago actors and it's being directed by the artistic director of the Goodman Theater, Susan Booth. I mean, she's incredible. She just directed Helen Hunt in Betrayal. So I can't wait. This is amazing. All right.
是的，它有一群非常棒的芝加哥本土演员，由古德曼剧院的艺术总监苏珊·布斯执导。我的意思是，她太不可思议了。她刚刚执导了海伦·亨特的《背叛》。所以我等不及了。这太棒了。好的。
Well, you know, I ran into Lindsay as well, but it was at an office fan convention. She made me laugh so hard. She's so funny. She's just so funny. And I loved catching up with her. We'll talk about that when she comes on too. Well, you all might know Lindsay from her roles
你知道的，我也碰到了林赛，但那是在一个动漫展上。她把我逗得哈哈大笑。她太搞笑了。她就是这么有趣。我很喜欢和她叙旧。等她上节目时我们再细聊。大家可能通过以下角色认识林赛：
in Get Him to the Greek, 21 Jump Street, and Hello Ladies. Most recently, you can catch her on the hit show Ghosts on CBS and HBO's Julia. And today, we dive in with her all about what it was like to play the foil to Jim and Pam's relationship. She has a lot to say about it. So we'll be right back after this break with Lindsay Broad. The all-new all-electric Can-Am Origin motorcycle takes you everywhere. Sleek power for the streets, deep adventure routes for the trails.
《前往希腊剧院》、《龙虎少年队》和《寻人密探lvy》。最近，你可以在CBS的热门剧集《鬼屋欢乐送》和HBO的《茱莉亚》中看到她的身影。今天，我们和她深入聊了聊，扮演吉姆和帕姆恋情中的搅局者是什么体验。她对此有很多话要说。休息一下，我们马上回来，对话林赛·布罗德。全新全电动Can-Am Origin摩托车带你去任何地方。为街道提供强劲动力，为小径提供深度探险路线。
Discover your origin today. Learn more at CanAmMotorcycles.com. Spring is here and you can now get almost anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? You can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get chicken parmesan delivered. Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now.
今天就探索你的起源。了解更多请访问CanAmMotorcycles.com。春天到了，现在你可以用Uber Eats配送几乎所有东西。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？你不能让人配送一片修剪完美的草坪，但你可以配送帕尔马鸡排。阳光？不行。来点红酒？可以。通过Uber Eats配送几乎、几乎任何东西。立即下单。
Alcohol in select markets. See after details. Hi Lindsay! Welcome to Office Ladies 6.0. We are so excited to have you here today. Oh my God, I'm glad I finally made it. I know, this has been a long time coming. I know, because my first, when you guys got to my episodes, it was during the actor strike. Correct, yes.
酒精限部分市场。查看后续详情。嗨，林赛！欢迎来到《办公室女士》6.0版。我们非常高兴今天你能来到这里。天哪，我很高兴我终于来了。我知道，这可以说是蓄势待发。我知道，因为我的第一集，当你们俩看到我的剧集时，正赶上演员罢工。没错，是的。
It's very heartbreaking, because I waited a long time for you guys to get there. I couldn't believe it. Well, we are so excited to dive in and we're going to start with the question that we ask all of our guests, which is how did you get your role on The Office? Okay, so I got my role on The Office. It was like sort of a process because when they cast the role of Jordan at the end of, I think the seventh season,
这让人心碎，因为我等你们看到那里等了好久。我简直不敢相信。好吧，我们非常兴奋地要深入探讨，我们要从问所有嘉宾的经典问题开始，你是怎么得到《办公室》里的角色的？好的，我得到《办公室》里的角色。这有点像是一个过程，因为当他们在第七季结束时为乔丹的角色选角时，
I had auditioned for that and I had heard through some secret sources that I was one of the choices. I didn't end up getting it. Then the following summer, I was in Spain with my sister and for the first time, I brought no recording equipment with me, I brought no Spain with my sister, and for the first time, I brought no recording equipment with me. I brought no makeup with me. And I got an audition for the role of Carla,
我试镜过那个角色，并通过一些秘密渠道听说我是候选人之一。我最后没能演成。然后接下来的夏天，我和我姐姐在西班牙，这是我第一次没有带任何录音设备，我和我姐姐去了西班牙，这是我第一次没有带任何录音设备。我没带任何化妆品。然后我接到了卡拉这个角色的试镜通知，
which ended up being Cathy, and I made a tape. And my manager at the time was like, I can't send this tape in. You... This tape is... He had never done that. We had worked together for years. He was like, this tape is so he had never done that. We had worked together for years. He was like, this tape is so bad.
这个角色最终成了凯西，我录了一段试带。当时的经纪人说，我不能把这个录像交上去。你……这个录像……他从来没这样做过。我们已经合作多年了。他说，这个录像太……他从来没这样做过。我们已经合作多年了。他说，这个录像太烂了。
You're doing nothing. And also like, you're like sweaty, like you don't have on. And I was like, well, yeah, I'm in Spain. There's like no air conditioning. So he didn't end up sending my tape in. And then the day I got back, I guess he still hadn't found someone. So I went and I read in person with
你什么都没演。而且你看上去像在流汗，什么都没化。我说，好吧，对啊，我在西班牙。那里根本没有空调。所以他最后没有把我的录像交上去。然后我回来的那天，我猜他还是没找到合适的人。于是我去现场读了剧本
Allison Jones and Ben and it was funny because I went in and I did more than I did on my initial tape and they brought me down down down till I was doing nothing aka what I did on my original tape. Your instincts? Yeah and I went to the laundromat and I was doing all of my laundry. And I got a text from BJ Novak that just said, yes, with an exclamation point, because he and I knew each other socially. And like an hour later, I got a call.
艾莉森·琼斯和本，有趣的是，我进去后表现得比我最初录带时还要夸张，他们一步步把我收敛回来，直到我什么都不做，也就是我在最初磁带里的表现。你的直觉？对，我去自助洗衣店洗了我所有的衣服。我收到一条来自B·J·诺瓦克的短信，上面只有一个感叹号的“好”，因为我和他在社交场合认识。大约一个小时后，我接到了电话。
It was like 6 o'clock. And I had to be on set at 5 AM the next morning. What? What? And where were you at the time? Were you in LA, or were you on the East Coast? I was in Los Angeles. Yeah, I was living in Los Angeles.
当时大概6点。我得在第二天早上5点到片场。什么？什么？你当时在哪里？你在洛杉矶，还是在东海岸？我在洛杉矶。对，我住在洛杉矶。
And I remember I was like, well, I'm gonna go get some sushi and take an Ambien and go to bed. And I had an Ambien in my house that I saved for exactly that purpose in case I ever got a job last minute and knew that I needed to get a good night of sleep and I was gonna be too anxious to sleep. I had no idea that we did not cast the part of
我记得当时我想，好吧，我要去吃点寿司，吃一颗安眠药然后睡觉。我家里有一颗安眠药，我是为了这种突发情况专门留着的，以防我哪天最后一分钟接到工作，知道自己需要好好睡一觉，而且会焦虑得睡不着。我根本不知道我们还没定下凯西这个角色
Kathy until the night before. I did not know that. Oh yeah and I had just gotten back from this like trip with my sister and I was feeling like you know when you've been traveling and I hadn't been on my phone basically for like a week and I was like tan and I was just also in that like travel loopy space. And I remember I was sharing a trailer with Zach Woods and he just came up to me, he's like, how are you doing? And I was like, I'm kind of having a nervous breakdown.
直到前一天晚上。我根本不知道。哦对，我刚和姐姐结束旅行回来，那种感觉就像你一直在旅行，我基本上有一周没看手机，我晒得很黑，也处于那种旅行后的晕乎状态。我记得我和扎克·伍兹共用一个化妆车，他走过来对我说，你最近怎么样？我说，我好像快精神崩溃了。
And he was like, yeah, you'll be okay. I love that Zach was your pep talk guy. Oh, yeah, I love Zach. Yeah. Had you been a fan of the show before? Had you watched it? I had watched all of it. I had watched all of it from the beginning.
他说，没事，你会好起来的。我太喜欢扎克作为你的专属啦啦队长了。哦，对，我超爱扎克。对。你之前是这部剧的粉丝吗？你看过吗？我全看过。从头到尾我都看过。
Oh yeah, I had watched all of it from the beginning. And it was the first time I had ever had a job on a show that I had watched. It was very surreal. It was the first time I had ever had a job on a show that I had watched. It was very surreal. It was very surreal. And what were you told about your character? Like, you got the job. You had 12 hours to prepare for this job.
哦对，我从头到尾都看过。这是我第一次参演一部我看过的剧。感觉非常超现实。这是我第一次参演一部我看过的剧。感觉非常超现实。这太超现实了。关于你的角色，他们跟你说了什么？比如，你得到了这份工作。你有12个小时来为这份工作做准备。
But like, what did you know? Did you know that you were going to be on multiple episodes? Did you know? I knew nothing. Did you know you were going to be this wedge sort of maybe between Pam and Jim? So okay, so here's what I knew. I knew I was hired for one episode. I knew it had the potential to recur and I had absolutely no information other than the fact that the character was described as Scranton Hott. So I was like, okay.
但你知道什么？你知道你会出演多集吗？你知道吗？我什么都不知道。你知道你会成为帕姆和吉姆之间可能存在的某种第三者吗？好吧，我知道的是：我被告知只录一集。我知道它有续签的可能，除了这个角色被描述为“斯克兰顿辣妹”之外，我没有任何其他信息。所以我想，好吧。
And it's funny because- Please tell me you have a t-shirt that says Scranton Hot, Lindsay. No, but if somebody wants to make it for me, I'm wearing my t-shirts very large these days. I would like a larger and extra large. I think Scranton Hot is a phenomenal t-shirt idea. Isn't that so funny? I know my husband has been looking for a long time for like a good vintage March Madness t-shirt idea. Isn't that so funny? I know my husband has been looking for a long time for like a good vintage March Madness t-shirt for me. Uh-huh. But I was like, I can't wear this in public.
有趣的是——求求你告诉我你有一件印着“斯克兰顿辣妹”的T恤，林赛。没有，但如果有人想为我做一件的话，我现在的T恤都穿得很大。我想要一件大码和加大码的。我觉得“斯克兰顿辣妹”是一个绝妙的T恤创意。难道不觉得很有趣吗？我知道我丈夫找一件好看的复古疯狂三月T恤找了很久。难道不觉得很有趣吗？我知道我丈夫一直想为我找一件好看的复古疯狂三月T恤。嗯哼。但我想，我不能在公共场合穿这个。
But anyway, yeah, so that was all I knew. And they would basically hire me, whatever, they would hire me at the last possible second for every episode. So I sort of just would like find out maybe like Friday night that I'd be back again Monday morning I always had a sense that I would be back But I never knew stressful. Oh, yeah, I never knew quite what was going on and Also, I don't know if you guys remember this but they would often Nobody quite knew... Looking back, I think the word they were looking for Kathy was basic, but that wasn't like a word in the vernacular at the time.
不管怎样，是的，这就是我当时知道的全部。他们基本上会在最后一秒钟雇我，无论如何，每一集都是在最后一秒雇我。所以我差不多就是在周五晚上才会发现我周一早上又要去上班了。我总有一种预感我会回去，但我从不知道这有多大压力。哦，是的，我从来不知道到底发生了什么。还有，我不知道你们记不记得，他们经常……没人能确准……回想起来，我觉得他们对凯西的定义其实是“势利/抓马/做作”，但当时这词还没在日常用语里流行。
And they didn't really quite... They kept trying different things on for her at the table reads. So like there was an episode, like the trivia episode, where all of a sudden out of nowhere, I had like gone to an Ivy League school and was really good at trivia, and it turns out I was really secretly smart. And then that got cut. And then I remember talking to one of the writers
他们其实并不十分确定……他们在台词围读时不断为她尝试不同的设定。所以有一集，比如知识竞赛那一集，不知从哪里冒出来，我突然变成了一个上过常春藤盟校、知识竞赛超级厉害的人，原来我一直是个隐藏的学霸。然后这段被剪掉了。接着我记得我跟其中一位编剧聊过
at the rap party, and they were like, "'Yeah, they just couldn't, "'they kept trying different things on, "'but it would never make it to the final draft.'" And then I think ultimately, I'm trying to remember when I figured out that I was gonna be the wedge, as you called it.
在杀青派对上，他们说：“对啊，他们就是拿不定主意，”“他们不断尝试不同的设定，”“但这些都没能进入最终剧本。”然后我想最终，我在努力回忆我是什么时候发现自己要演那个所谓的第三者的。
Was it in Pam's replacement? Like, was it? Because that was your first episode and Jim and Kathy have, you know, those scenes where they're laughing and she brings up Zoolander. And so there's a little bit of stuff happening there. Yeah. I remember her being like, okay, she's like kind of a cool girl. And there was all the discussions about whether like that whole episode, I think there's like a whole discussion
是在帕姆的替代者那一集吗？是吗？因为那是你的第一集，吉姆和凯西有那些他们一起笑、她还提到《名模大间谍》的戏份。所以那里已经有一点苗头了。对。我记得她的设定类似于，好吧，她有点像个酷女孩。而且大家都在讨论，整集都在讨论，我记得好像有一整场讨论
about whether or not I'm attractive. And yeah, I want to say the storyline with Cathy and Jim happened, I want to say like my, at the very end of my storyline. And I remember when I first realized it was going in that direction and I was just like, oh no. Oh no. I was excited because I was like, oh, this will be fun. I'll have stuff to do. But I just remember being like, oh no. They're going to come for me.
关于我到底有没有吸引力。是的，我想说凯西和吉姆的故事线发生在我故事线的尾声。我记得当我第一次意识到剧情在往这个方向发展时，我就想，哦不。哦不。我当时很兴奋，因为我想，哦，这会很有趣。我会有事情可做了。但我只记得当时心想：哦不。他们要来找我了。
You knew. Yeah. But you know what? I feel like nobody really came for me in the moment. It was later on. It was sort of, you know, I'm sure you guys experienced too, that sort of like second wind,
你知道的。是啊。但你知道吗？我觉得当时真的没有人来找我。是后来才发生的。就是那种，你知道的，我相信你们也经历过，那种所谓的第二春，
like during the Netflix Comedy Central rerun era, and all of a sudden, that's when I started feeling a lot of attention. Yeah, I mean, we've said, we think that you, Rashida, and Chris Diamantopoulos should all like start a support group. And Rich Summer, yes of course.
就像在 Netflix 和喜剧中心（Comedy Central）重播的时代，突然之间，我开始感觉到有很多关注。是啊，我的意思是，我们说过，我们觉得你、拉什达（Rashida）和克里斯·迪亚曼托普洛斯（Chris Diamantopoulos）应该一起组建一个互助小组。还有里奇·萨默（Rich Sommer），当然还有他。
Yes, because it wasn't easy. We actually, we got a fan question, a fan mail flurry of people wanting to know, did you and do you still get hate for hitting on gym? And Elizabeth B. from Buckley, Washington said, did you expect the backlash to affect your real life? So here's what I'll say. As far as I know, it doesn't really affect my real life because my real life I compartmentalize. I use the same last name as my kids.
是的，因为这并不容易。我们实际上收到了一条粉丝提问，一大堆粉丝来信，大家想知道，你当时有因为调戏吉姆而招致骂名吗？现在还有吗？来自华盛顿州巴克利的伊丽莎白·B（Elizabeth B.）说：“你有没有料到这种强烈的反对会影响你的现实生活？”所以我想说的是：据我所知，它并没有真正影响到我的现实生活，因为我对现实生活进行了隔离。我和我的孩子用同一个姓氏。
I try to be pretty unassuming in my real life. So I don't know how much it bleeds over into how certain people see me or treat me. Occasionally if I meet somebody and they just like really don't like me despite the fact that I'm being very friendly, I'm always like in the back of my head like, is that what it is? But I will say the internet is just a really crazy place. And there was a moment, I tweeted something back when I used to be on Twitter when my dog was killed. And I had posted on Instagram that my dog had died. And there was a bunch of comments underneath being like, fuck you, Kathy, you deserve it.
我尽量在现实生活中保持低调。所以我不知道它有多少会渗透到某些人看我或对待我的方式中。偶尔如果我遇到一个人，尽管我很友好，但他们就是真的很不喜欢我，我脑海深处总会想：就是因为这个吗？但我得说，互联网真的是一个非常疯狂的地方。曾经有那么一次，当我还用推特时，我发了一条推文，那是关于我的狗去世的事情。我曾在 Instagram 上发过我狗去世的消息。然后下面有一堆评论说：去你的，凯西，你活该。
And I had then tweeted about that, and then that kind of went viral. And then I still get engagement on this years old tweet, and so people always ask me about it. Here's what I will say. The internet is a crazy place. I've gotten used to people calling me Kathy. However, when I meet people in real life,
然后我为此发了一条推文，接着那条推文就有点火了。然后直到现在，几年后的这条推文上仍然有人互动，所以人们总是问我这件事。我要说的是：互联网是一个疯狂的地方。我已经习惯了人们叫我凯西。然而，当我在现实生活中遇到人们时，
people are so excited. If people are big enough fans of The Office that they can recognize me, and again, I think I'm like sort of an unassuming looking person. I'm not like very flashy looking. So if they recognize me, they're like a big fan. People are so excited to see somebody from this show
大家都会非常兴奋。如果有人是《办公室》的超级粉丝，能认出我来——而且再说一次，我觉得我长得挺普通的，看起来不是那种很张扬的人。所以如果他们认出了我，他们绝对是真爱粉。大家见到剧中的演员都太兴奋了，
that they are just incredibly nice. The internet is like a different story. Yeah, yeah. And that is so true. I mean, you and I ran into each other at this office fan convention last year and I hadn't been to the big, the office fan convention and everybody that comes there,
以至于他们都极其友善。互联网则是完全不同的一回事。对，对。这太对了。我的意思是，去年你在一个《办公室》粉丝见面会上碰到了我，我以前没去过大型的《办公室》粉丝见面会，所有去那里的人，
just their love for the show is so pure and wonderful. And it's like this show that brings people together from all over the world. And I left with such a positive experience from that. And they're excited to meet every single person. They wanna meet every single person that was on the show. And I just think that the fan base is really awesome in that way.
他们对这部剧的爱是那么纯粹和美好。这就好比是一部将来自世界各地的人们聚集在一起的剧集。我带着非常积极的体验离开了那里。他们很高兴能见到每一个人。他们想见到剧中的每一个演员。我觉得粉丝群体在这一点上真的很棒。
Yeah, it's really sweet. And I always think about, you know, there is this, I remember reading one of the actors from Lost who was saying, if you can just show up and like make somebody's day by showing up, then it's kind of hard not to do something like that. And I feel like the fan community of the show is so sweet. But the other thing that's so wild to me is how broad it is.
对，真的很温馨。我总是会想起，你知道的，有这么一件事，我记得读过《迷失》（Lost）里的一位演员说过，如果你只要露面就能让某人的一天变得美好，那么不做这样一件事就说不过去了。我觉得这部剧的粉丝群体非常可爱。但让我感到震惊的另一件事是，它的受众面竟然如此之广。
Yeah. Um, and I remember actually when I was cast on the show, I went to drinks with a friend of mine who's a comedy writer. And he was like, you're on Cheers. This is like being on Cheers. You know, like something that like people, and actually now I would say that, dare I say like it's a larger phenomenon than Cheers is that many years later. But I remember at the time being like, okay, this is something that will probably be in my obituary, which is like a very crazy thing to have associated with something that you did for, you know,
是的。嗯，我甚至记得当我被选中出演这部剧时，我和一个做喜剧编剧的朋友去喝了杯酒。他说：“你在《欢乐酒店》（Cheers）里。这就跟在《欢乐酒店》里一样。”你知道的，就像那种人们……其实现在我要说的是，我甚至敢说，多年后它比《欢乐酒店》造成的现象还要宏大。但我记得当时我想的是：“好吧，这大概会出现在我的讣告里。”这真是一件疯狂的事，竟然会和你在一个只干了……
a period of like five months. And it's sort of immortal and like a very cool way. And I think I had a sense of that when it was happening. And still, it's really wild to me the degree to which it sort of like leads over into my personal life. Because again, I like don't make a show, you know, I have two kids. I never make it clear to anybody. Like I don't talk about being an actress or anything like that at their school. And it's always funny to me when eventually, like people have known me long enough
大约五个月的项目联系在一起。它以一种非常酷的方式变得永恒。当这一切发生的时候，我其实就有一种预感。即便如此，它在某种程度上渗透到我的个人生活中的程度，对我来说仍然非常疯狂。因为再说一次，我并不怎么做节目，你知道的，我有两个孩子。我在学校里从来不向任何人明确表露这一点——我不会谈论自己是个演员之类的话题。每当人们最终认识我足够久，
that they finally are like, can I ask you about? Like, let me talk to you about this. Like, I made it through all of last year, an entire year of preschool without anybody ever acknowledging it. And then it was funny because Helen Coleman, who played Isabelle, is a good friend of mine. And she came to my son's birthday party last summer.
终于开始问我：“我能问你个问题吗？……能跟我聊聊这个吗？”时，我总是觉得很好笑。比如去年，我整整一年的学前班生活都安然无恙地度过了，没有任何人认出我来。然后有趣的是，扮演伊莎贝尔（Isabelle）的海伦·科尔曼（Helen Coleman）是我的好朋友。去年夏天她来参加了我儿子的生日派对。
And I remember mentioning this to a group of my friends, like my preschool mom friends. And they were like, we know. And I was like, see, that's the thing with me is that if you're just chill and you don't mention it for a full year, you never know who's going to show up at the birthday party. And they were all like, yeah. Oh, I love that. And you know, Lindsay, I felt like so protective of you when those comments came out on your post about losing your dog.
我记得我向我的一群朋友——也就是学前班妈妈朋友们——提起过这件事，她们说：“我们早就知道了。”我说：“看吧，这就是我，如果你为人随和，而且整整一年都不提这事，你永远不知道谁会出现在生日派对上。”她们都说：“是啊。”哦，我太喜欢这个了。你知道吗，林赛（Lindsay），当那些针对你失去爱犬帖子的恶评出现时，我对你有一种强烈的保护欲。
Because I know that, you know, we only had like two episodes together. We had the first episode and basically the last episode of your arc, and then I was on real maternity leave. But my experience of you was that you were such a kind and genuine person, and we're very protective of our office family. So it has bothered me that that happened. But I love hearing all of this about like getting to go to the fan convention and getting to feel the love of being part of this story.
因为我知道，你知道的，我们只一起拍了两集。我们在你的戏份的第一集和基本上最后一集合作过，之后我就去休真正的产假了。但在我的体验中，你是一个非常善良和真诚的人，而且我们对我们的办公室大家庭有着很强的保护欲。所以发生那种事让我觉得很困扰。但我很高兴听到这一切，比如能够去参加粉丝见面会，并感受到成为这个故事一部分的爱。
Yeah, and I think it's especially like, I'll say that in New York City, you know, when I am walking around and it's happened like with my kids, when people spot you on the street and they want a selfie or you're like at Whole Foods and they just want a selfie, which was very confusing to my children for a long time, it's like the energy of it is so sweet. People love this show in such an intense way that it's really cool to be involved in something
对，而且我觉得尤其是——我可以说在纽约市，你知道的，当我四处走动时，就像我带着孩子时发生的那样，当人们在街上认出你并想要一张自拍，或者你在全食超市（Whole Foods）偶遇他们，他们只是想要张自拍——这让我的孩子们困惑了很久——那种氛围真的很温馨。人们对这部剧的喜爱是如此强烈，以至于能参与到这样一部作品中真的很酷，
that people have such an intimacy with this show. And it's a very, yeah, the parasocial thing is pretty cool. It's really cool to be involved in something that people have such an intimacy with this show. Yeah. And it's a very, yeah, the parasocial thing is pretty cool. Can we ask you about a few different moments in your episodes? Yeah. So, I was rewatching them last night and you're so good and you're so likable. Like, I mean, obviously once we get to Florida, if you're rooting for Jim and Pam, you are
人们对这部剧有着如此亲近的感觉。而且这是一种非常……对，这种准社会交往（parasocial）真的挺酷的。能参与到这样一部作品中真的很酷，人们对这部剧有着如此亲近的感觉。而且这是一种非常……对，这种准社会交往真的挺酷的。我们能问问你剧集里的几个不同片段吗？行。所以，我昨晚重温了这些剧集，你演得太棒了，太讨人喜欢了。我的意思是，很显然，一旦我们到了佛罗里达，如果你支持吉姆和帕姆，你就会觉得……
like, hey, Kathy, whoa, whoa, whoa, pump the brakes. But in Pam's replacement, you're just like, just such a nice normal person in the office. But then there's the episode Gettysburg. And Lindsay, I did not realize in our tiny conference room scene, because half of everyone goes with Andy, right, on the field trip. And then there's only a small group of us left in the office and we end up in the conference room scene pitching our, you know, think outside the box ideas. And you were seated the whole time next to James Spader
“嘿，凯西，哇，哇，哇，踩刹车。”但作为帕姆的替代者，你在办公室里就像是一个如此友好、正常的普通人。然后就是《葛底斯堡战役》（Gettysburg）那一集。林赛，我以前没有意识到在我们那个微型会议室的场景里——因为每个人的一半都跟着安迪去实地考察了，对吧？然后办公室里只剩下一小群人，我们最后在会议室里提出我们的“打破常规”的想法。而你全程都坐在詹姆斯·斯派德（James Spader）旁边
in the back row. And I did not even realize that. And I always enjoyed our conference room scene so much. What was that conference room scene like for you? I just remember any time I was in that scenario where I was sort of like a fly on the wall, which worked because that's how she would have been as a temp, I just kind of sat back
的最后一排。我甚至都没意识到这一点。我一直非常喜欢我们的会议室那场戏。对你来说，那个会议室的场景是怎样的？我只记得每当我处于那种场景中、就像墙角的一只苍蝇时——这很合适，因为作为临时工她本该如此——我就只是往后一靠，
and watched the show, if that makes sense. And I knew, you know, if I remember correctly, and you guys can correct me if I remember this incorrectly, they would do a straight take, right? Where they would get all the words that were on the page. And then they would get a take that was looser, where everybody was really playing around. And so it was always very fun for me,
看着大家飙戏，如果这么说能懂的话。而且我知道，如果我没记错的话——如果我记错了，你们可以纠正我——他们会先拍一条严格按照剧本的，对吧？就是剧本上写什么就说台词。然后他们会拍一条比较放松的，每个人都在里面尽情发挥。所以对我来说总是非常有趣，
especially that many years into the show, to watch this ensemble of people who knew how to play with each other. And I mean, the pool party episode really stands out. Like I remember that episode was really cool because everybody was in it, like for that week. I have a photo of all of us in the pool, like a selfie. You do?
尤其是拍摄这部剧好几年之后，看着这群知道如何互相配合的演员。我的意思是，“泳池派对”那一集真的很突出。我还记得那一集特别酷，因为每个人都在里面，就那一周而言。我有一张我们所有人都在泳池里的照片，就像是一张自拍照。你有？
Yes, I found it when we were- Oh my God, can you send it to me? Yes, I will. I was going through pictures for Jenna and I's book and I found it. And it's like the quality of it. One of the reasons we didn't use it is, I think I took it with like a flip phone.
对，我们在——天哪，你能发给我吗？好，我会的。我当时在为我和珍娜（Jenna）的书翻找照片，然后我找到了它。它的画质……我们没用它的原因之一，我想我是用翻盖手机拍的。
I don't know. Yeah. But it is, it's us in the water. And that episode was so bonkers. I just remember that. I have no photos. I have no photos? I literally never took a single photo ever.
我不知道。对。但那是真的，是我们泡在水里的照片。那一集太疯狂了。我只记得这个。我没有照片。我一张照片也没有？我真的从来没拍过一张照片。
Oh, I will get that for you. I will go dig and find it. Isn't that crazy? Well, the pool party episode's so funny to me because I don't know what it was like for you guys, but I remember it was like a Thursday or a Friday and they were like, um, Lindsay wardrobe needs you. Um, wardrobe just needs you. They need to fit your swimsuit. I was like, my swimsuit? They were like, yeah, for the next episode. This is called The Office? What? They were like, the next episode is called Pool Party. And I was like, and meanwhile, like, I mean, I had been working, because I was in the background of all the
哦，我会帮你弄到的。我会去挖出来找找。这不挺疯狂的吗？嗯，“泳池派对”那一集对我来说太搞笑了，因为我不知道你们当时是怎么想的，但我记得那是周四还是周五，他们突然说：“嗯，林赛，服装组找你。”“嗯，服装组只是需要你。他们需要量一下你的泳衣尺寸。”我说：“我的泳衣？”他们说：“对，为了下一集。”这剧叫《办公室》？什么？他们说：“下一集叫‘泳池派对’。”然后我说：与此同时，我的意思是，我一直在工作，因为我是所有
confessionals, I was always in the background and they shot those at the end of the day. And so I was always the first person in because I was the last person hired. So I was in the earliest to get my hair and makeup done. And then I was the last person out. So I was working. I didn't even have food in my refrigerator during that period of time. And I certainly wasn't working out. And I just remember being like, pool party. And when they went to my fitting, they were like, well, you can wear a one piece. And I was like, but she wouldn't wear a one piece, like integrity, like obviously she'd be in a two piece.
访谈镜头的背景板，我总是在背景里，而那些镜头都是在一天结束时拍摄的。所以我总是第一个到，因为我是最后一个被招进来的。所以我最早去弄头发和化妆。然后我是最后一个离开的。所以我一直在工作。在那段时间里，我的冰箱里甚至连食物都没有。我当然也没有去健身。我只记得当时想：“泳池派对？”当我去试穿时，他们说：“哦，你可以穿连体泳衣。”我说：“但她才不会穿连体泳衣呢，为了角色的一致性，很显然她应该穿比基尼。”
So I let them put me in like a bikini. And then I showed up to set and I think I was the only one in a bikini. And I felt so dumb. And then Charles McDougall, who directed that episode who I've since worked with, had a shot where he wanted me like getting up, I don't think they ended up using it,
所以我让他们给我换上了一套比基尼。然后我来到片场，我想我是唯一一个穿比基尼的人。我当时觉得自己蠢透了。然后导演那一集的查尔斯·麦克杜格尔（Charles McDougall）——我后来还和他合作过——有一个镜头，他想让我从水里站起来——我想他们最后没用这个镜头，
but I had to like get up out of the pool right in front of the camera and then just like my butt walked by the camera. And I was just like, I can't believe this is happening. It's so funny, we talked to Ellie Kemper about that episode too, and she had the same reaction. She was like sat down at the table read and was like, pool party, huh?
但我不得不从正对着摄像机的泳池里站起来，然后我的屁股就这样从摄像机前走过。我当时就想：我不敢相信这正在发生。太搞笑了，我们跟埃利·肯珀（Ellie Kemper）也聊过那一集，她也有同样的反应。她当时坐在剧本围读的桌旁，心想：“泳池派对，是吧？”
Interesting. Yeah. Yeah. I thought the same thing because my character was quote unquote, eight months pregnant, but like fake pregnant. And I was like, pool party, okay. How are you guys gonna do this?
有意思。对。是的，我也这么想，因为我的角色当时号称怀孕八个月，但其实是假怀孕。我就想：“泳池派对，好吧。你们打算怎么拍？”
But they found a way, Lindsey, I don't know if you remember. Did you have a sarong? I feel like, did you have a sarong? I had, they wanted me in the background swimming laps with a kickboard. Oh, that's right. Yeah, at first they had me swimming laps, but they also had me put this fake belly in a maternity bathing suit. What they didn't factor in is that that fake belly absorbed water. And I literally was like, I'm going to drown. So then they got me a kickboard because I was like sinking. And then I would get out of the pool and it was as if I was peeing for like an hour as I walked around because that thing
但他们想出了办法，林赛，我不知道你还记不记得。你当时有纱丽（sarong）围裙吗？我觉得，你当时有吗？我……他们想让我在背景里用浮板游来游去。哦，对。是的，一开始他们让我游来游去，但他们还让我穿上孕妇泳衣戴上假肚子。他们没有考虑到的是，那个假肚子会吸水。我当时真的觉得：“我要溺水了。”所以他们后来给我拿了一块浮板，因为我在往下沉。然后我从泳池里爬出来，在我走动的时候，感觉就像尿了一个小时一样，因为那个东西
was like leaking water. Well, I remember Mindy and I were in the background of somebody else's scene and we were supposed to be like, I don't know, doing something, and we decided we were going to be doing shots. But then we were basically just doing shots for like four, like pretending to do shots for four hours. So we just kept having to pee because we just kept drinking like whatever it was. But also when you, when you pretend to do shots for that long, you just start to feel a little loopy, like you start to feel a little drunk. I just remember doing that for like, and it was in that gorgeous mansion in Pasadena.
一直在漏水。嗯，我记得我和敏迪（Mindy）在别人的场景背景里，我们本该假装……我不知道，做点什么，然后我们决定要假装喝酒（doing shots）。但后来我们其实就是连续四小时一直在假装喝酒，假装喝了四个小时的酒。所以我们一直得去上厕所，因为我们不停地喝着杯子里的东西，不管那是什么。而且，当你假装喝酒那么久之后，你就会开始觉得有点晕乎乎的，就像有点喝醉了一样。我只记得拍那个拍了好久，那是帕萨迪纳的一栋豪华豪宅里。
Yeah. Anyway, I have very fond memories of that episode, aside from the bathing suit. Thursday, May 8th is McHappy Day when every menu item purchased at McDonald's helps support families with sick children. So you can feel the good that comes from doing good, just from ordering. So if I order a Big Mac, I'm helping. Yup. What about a McFlurry?
不管怎样，除了泳衣之外，我对那一集有着非常美好的回忆。5月8日星期四是麦当劳的“麦公德日”（McHappy Day），当天在麦当劳购买的每款菜单单品都将用于帮助支持患病儿童的家庭。因此，只需下单，你就能感受到行善带来的美好。所以如果我点一个巨无霸，我就是在帮忙？没错。那麦旋风（McFlurry）呢？
10 piece chicken McNuggets and apple pie? You got it. Every single order helps. Join us at McDonald's for McHappy Day on Thursday, May 8th. Do good, feel good. A portion of food and beverage sales will support RMHC chapters and local children's charities across Canada. I have to go back to Pam's replacement
10块麦乐鸡和苹果派？没问题。每一笔订单都在献一份力。5月8日星期四，加入我们在麦当劳举办的“麦公德日”。行善，感受美好。部分食品和饮料销售额将用于支持加拿大各地的麦当劳叔叔之家慈善基金会（RMHC）分会和当地儿童慈善机构。我得回到帕姆的替代者那一集，
because there is a scene in Pam's replacement that I have to ask you about. So it's the scene where Dwight is going to see if Jim has an erection. Yes. How did you do it, Lindsay? This is like you were thrown into this ridiculousness of these two guys.
因为帕姆的替代者里有一个场景我必须问问你。就是德怀特去查看吉姆是不是有勃起反应的那个场景。对。你是怎么做到的，林赛？这就好像你被卷入了这两个家伙的荒唐戏码中。
You were not breaking. Like you were. That was my first day. I know. It was? Yeah. I knew it was one of your very first days. And we did that scene for so long
你居然没有笑场。就像你——那是我的第一天。我知道。那是吗？对。我知道那是你的头几天之一。我们那个场景拍了超级久，
because the two of them couldn't hold it together and you were in frame and you were holding it together. I'm like laughing off camera, watching all of it. And I remember on the day thinking, how is she doing it? She is so solid. She is amazing. Cause the whole time I was just like, don't get fired. Don't get fired.
因为他俩根本憋不住笑，而你一直在镜头里却稳如泰山。我在镜头外看着这一切都在笑。我记得当时在片场想：“她是怎么做到的？她太稳了。她太厉害了。”因为我全程都在想：“别被炒鱿鱼。别被炒鱿鱼。
Don't get fired. No, I would think I was just, well, here's a funny story about Pam's replacement. So I am sitting at your desk, right? You put me in your desk. And Matt's own, who was the DP of most of the series who directed a lot of the episodes towards the end, he was directing that episode. And I remember he kept saying to me, like every time the camera would roll, he would
别被炒鱿鱼。”不，我当时只是——好吧，关于帕姆的替代者有一个有趣的故事。我当时坐在你的办公桌前，对吧？你让我坐在你的桌子后面。马特·佐恩（Matt Sohn），他是大部分剧集的摄影指导（DP），也导演了最后一季的很多集，他当时在导演那一集。我记得他不停地对我说——每次摄像机一开始拍摄，他就会
sort of go, sit up straight? Sit up straight? And I got to this point where like I've always had bad posture. So I'm like, oh my God. And I kept just being like, I don't, I couldn't, I was like stretching my neck, like I could not possibly be sitting more straight. And I'm just the entire time like, I'm gonna get fired.
说上一句：“坐直？坐直？”我当时甚至觉得——我一直以来驼背挺严重的。所以我想：“噢天哪。”我一直忍不住在想：我不会……我做不到。我一直在伸长脖子，心想：我绝对不可能坐得更直了。我整个过程都在想：“我要被炒鱿鱼了。”
Like I'm gonna get fired because I can't sit up straight. And then all of a sudden, Rain was like, why are you so low? You look like a hobbit. You're like a hobbit down there. And that's when we realized because you were pregnant, they had lowered the seat because there had to be room for your belly. Oh my gosh.
“我要被炒鱿鱼了，因为我坐不直。”然后突然之间，雷恩（Rainn）说：“你为什么坐得这么低？你看起来像个霍比特人。你在下面就像个霍比特人。”然后我们才意识到，因为你当时怀孕了，他们把椅子调低了，因为得给你的肚子留出空间。噢天哪。
Because you were actually pregnant. So that my belly could fit under the desk. So the seat was dropped all the way down. So it just looked like I was like under the desk, like this. And so I spent, I was so freaked out from that incident where I was convinced I was getting fired because I didn't know how to sit up straight
因为你当时真的怀孕了。为了让我的肚子能塞进桌子底下。所以椅子被降到了最低。所以看起来就像我猫在桌子底下一样，像这样。所以我花了很多时间……我被那次经历吓坏了，我深信自己要被开除，因为我不知道该怎么坐直，
and I had such bad posture that I think I was just like, I was like in that zone where I was just, listen, I'm also a very serious actor, so I was just taking it off. Yeah, I don't know. I have no idea. And I get tagged in those videos all the time because I think the outtakes are on maybe the DVDs
而且我驼背太严重了，以至于我觉得自己当时就是处于那种状态——听着，我也是个非常认真的演员，所以我只是在全情投入。对，我不知道。我完全不知道。我经常被圈进那些视频里，因为我觉得花絮可能收录在DVD里，
or whatever. Yeah, the bloopers are on the DVDs and on YouTube. Yeah, so I'm always tagged in those and it's just so funny because all I remember from that day was just like, being like, I can't believe I made it here and now I'm gonna get fired. Well, you do break in after hours when there's that whole bed bug scene.
或者别的什么地方。对，NG花絮都在DVD和YouTube上。对，所以我总是被@在那些视频里，真的太搞笑了，因为我从那天唯一记住的事就是心想：“我不敢相信我来到了这里，而现在我要被炒鱿鱼了。”嗯，当有那个臭虫（bed bug）场景时，你确实在下班后破门而入了。
Yeah. You break so hard, you face plant it in the bed. Like you fall into the bed. I was exhausted. Yeah. But there's no way I could have got through that. No way. We just shot that scene for so long that I just, I feel like I was in that hotel room
对。你笑场得太厉害了，脸直接趴在床上了。就像你摔倒在床上一样。我当时筋疲力尽了。对。但我是绝对没办法憋住不笑的。绝无可能。我们那个场景拍了太久，我感觉我在那间酒店房间里
for days. I mean, I was in that hotel room for days. I mean, I was in a hotel room for days. And the thing is, is it was shot in a real hotel room in the Valley and they had, I think they had Video Village, which is where everybody, all the producers and everybody sits and watches what's on the monitors. But because it was such a tight space,
呆了好几天。我的意思是，我在那间酒店房间里呆了好几天。问题是，那是山谷（Valley）的一家真正的酒店房间里拍摄的，他们当时好像有视频监视村（Video Village），也就是所有制片人和其他所有人坐着看监视器画面的地方。但因为空间实在太狭窄了，
they had like one monitor in the bathroom. And I think the only two people there, it was the director and Brian Baumgartner directed that episode. And... Warren and Halstead, I think they wrote that one. Warren and Halstead wrote that episode. And so they were the only ones there. And I just remember we shot that episode for what?
他们只有一个监视器放在浴室里。而且现场仅有的两个人，一个是导演——布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳（Brian Baumgartner）导演了那一集，还有……沃伦和霍尔斯特德（Warren and Halstead），我想他们是那一集的编剧。沃伦和霍尔斯特德是那一集的编剧。所以现场只有他们俩。我只记得那一集我们拍了多久？
We shot those scenes for a very long time. So I think, not to like dispel anybody else's fantasy, but I think by the time we got there, I was just tired. You were loopy. I might have fallen onto the bed because I was just exhausted. Yeah. Lindsay, I have a memory of being there and watching some of those scenes. Do you have this memory?
我们那些场景拍了非常非常久。所以我想，并不是为了打消任何人的幻想，但我觉得当我们拍到那里时，我已经累瘫了。你当时脑子都转不动了。我可能真的是直接倒在床上的，因为我实在太累了。林赛，我记忆中我当时也在现场，还看了其中的一些场景。你有这段记忆吗？
How would I be there? Because you call, because Jim and Pam have a phone conversation. It's in the super fan episode. I think that I came up and did my off-camera dialogue. Did you? Maybe you just came to say hi. I have a strong memory of watching that bedbug scene
我怎么会去现场？因为你打电话——因为吉姆和帕姆有一通电话交谈。那是在超级粉丝剪辑版（super fan episode）里。我想我是过去录制了我的画外音对话。是吗？也许你只是去打个招呼。我对看那个臭虫的场景
on the monitors. And I remember, like, calling you, Angela, and saying, I just watched one of the funniest things we've ever shot for The Office. Yeah. Yeah. But there is a whole Jim and Pam phone call. There is.
在监视器上的画面有着深刻的记忆。我记得，就像，打电话给你，安吉拉，然后说：“我刚刚看到了我们在《办公室》里拍过的最搞笑的片段之一。”对。对。不过确实有一整段吉姆和帕姆的电话通话。确实有。
And it wasn't deleted scenes, but now it made it into this super fan extended cut. But it also was something that we rewrote and rewrote and rewrote. Like, once we got to this, like, set of episodes where Kathy is going to full throttle go for gym, I just, I think that's also why I have such a strong memory of being there, because I feel like there
而且这不是被删减片段，它现在被剪进了这个超级粉丝加长剪辑版里。但这也是我们一遍又一遍反复重写的内容。一旦我们到了凯西要全力以赴追求吉姆的这组剧集，我——我觉得这也是为什么我对现场印象那么深，因为我觉得当时
was a lot of discussion about. Well, did John, did John loop you in? Here's what I- Yeah, like you- Here's what I remember. Taking a shower, like all this stuff, like I just remember it changing, changing, changing. Yeah, the initial draft of that script that I remember, and I wish I had it. I wonder if I do have it somewhere like in my files, but- I was looking at it this morning.
有很多关于……嗯，约翰——约翰有把你拉进群吗？这是我——对，就像你——这是我记得的。洗澡之类的，所有这些东西——我只记得它一直在变，一直在变，一直在变。对，我记得那个剧本的最初版本，我真希望我有它。我不知道我有没有把它存在哪里的文件里，但——我今天早上还在看它。
Oh, I would love to read it. The initial draft that I remember was a lot more ambiguous. And I know that there's, again, Google alerts I get on myself all the time, or that like we were going to do something. That is not my memory. My memory is that it was a much more ambiguous thing where you were kind of in Jim's perspective that it was a much more ambiguous thing
哦，我很想读读它。我记得的最初版本要含糊得多。而且我知道，又是这样，我总能收到关于我自己的谷歌快讯（Google alerts），或者说我们本来要做点别的。那不是我的记忆。我的记忆是，这是一个含糊得多的版本，你有点像是站在吉姆的角度——这是一个含糊得多的版本，
where you were kind of in Jim's perspective of like, is she hitting on me? Is she not hitting on me? Yeah, that's what I remember too, Lindsay. Yeah, so I remember. I don't remember, there was never in any draft, there was never a moment where Jim was gonna kiss Kathy or Kathy was gonna kiss Jim. No, there was a moment where he, there's the moment where Jim was gonna kiss Kathy or Kathy was gonna kiss Jim? No, there was a moment where he,
你站在吉姆的角度，比如：她是在挑逗我吗？她没有在挑逗我吗？对，这也是我的记忆，林赛。对，所以我记得。我记不得了——在任何草稿里，从来没有过吉姆要亲吻凯西或者凯西要亲吻吉姆的时刻。没有，曾经有过一个时刻，他——有一个吉姆要亲吻凯西或者凯西要亲吻吉姆的时刻？没有，曾经有过一个时刻，他——
there's the moment where he says, like, hey, like, I think you're, I don't remember his exact lines, but he says something along the lines of like, hey, I feel like you're basically hitting on me. Yeah, he says, I think I just need to call this out. I'm married. And then Kathy's like, what do you think I'm doing?
有这样一个时刻，他说，呃，嘿，呃，我想你……我不记得他的原话了，但他的意思是，嘿，我觉得你基本上是在勾引我。对，他说，我想我需要直说这一点。我已经结婚了。然后凯西就说，你觉得我在干什么？
Initially, in the script, and I'll remember this forever, cause it was very fun to shoot, Cathy said to him, oh my God, like, why does this always happen to me? Oh my God, I know you're married. And I remember shooting it and falling back on the bed, like, and John as Jim just being like, what do I do here? Like, he was sort of like doing his thing.
最初在剧本里——我会永远记得这个，因为拍起来太好玩了——凯西对他说，哦我的天哪，呃，为什么这种事总是发生在我身上？哦我的天，我知道你结婚了。我记得当时在拍的时候，我往后倒在床上，那种感觉，然后作为吉姆的约翰就一脸，我在这里该怎么办？就像，他当时在按他自己的节奏演。
And then I kind of like threw myself back on the bed, and I'm like, this is so embarrassing. I don't understand why this keeps happening to me. Obviously, I know you're married, and it was much more ambiguous, and then there was the thing where then I take the shower, and I come in, and I'm like, I'm so cold. And the whole idea was, his head was just like,
然后我有点像把自己往后摔在床上，我说，这太尴尬了。我不明白为什么这种事一直发生在我身上。很显然，我知道你结婚了。而且这（台词）要暧昧得多，然后还有我去洗澡，接着走进来，然后说，我好冷。整个设想就是，他的脑子里就在想，
is she or isn't she? What is going on? Yeah, and in the shooting draft, yeah, you say that. You're like, why does this always happen to me? And then Jim gets embarrassed and feels bad. He's like, oh, do whatever you want. I don't care. I just, you know, great.
她到底是不是那个意思？这到底是怎么回事？对，在拍摄初稿里，对，你是这么说的。你会说，为什么这种事总是发生在我身上？然后吉姆就觉得很尴尬，心里很不是滋味。他说，哦，你想怎样就怎样吧。我不在乎。我只——你知道的，太好了。
You know I'm married, great. But wait, in the episode before, when you find out that you're going to Tallahassee with him, Kathy has a little phone call where she says to her friend. The tag. Yes. The tag where I'm holding my...
你知道我已经结婚了，太好了。但是等等，在前一集里，当你发现自己要和他一起去塔拉哈西时，凯西有一个简短的电话，她在电话里跟她的朋友说。片尾彩蛋。对。那个我在拿着我的……
I don't know if this is too much for the office ladies, but I was holding the handle of my wheelie suitcase. And I remember I was just sort of holding the handle and I was just sort of like going like this while we were shooting it and they were like, Lindsay, you have to stop with your hand up and down like that. It's like really, really inappropriate. It just looks a little bit weird. Standards and practices is going to come if we, if we shoot that. Yeah. But so I think the initial episode was much more ambiguous, but John thought it was too ambiguous. So then set shut down for about four hours.
我不知道这对于办公室女士（播客）来说是不是有点出格，但我当时抓着我那个带轮子的行李箱的把手。我记得我当时就只是抓着把手，我们在拍的时候，我就一直在那里像这样晃来晃去，然后他们就说，林赛，你不能再把手这样上下晃了。这真的、真的很不合适。看起来有点怪。如果我们、如果我们拍了这个，（电视台的）播出标准与审查部门就要来找麻烦了。对。所以我觉得最初的那集要暧昧得多，但约翰觉得太暧昧了。于是剧组停工了大约四个小时。
I swear to God, I was there. You might have been. You were a producer and if you were there doing your dialogue, Jenna, you would have been there. Part of this discussion. Yeah. Yeah. I don't even know how much anybody was part of it.
我发誓，我当时就在现场。你可能也在。你是制片人，而且如果你当时在那儿念你的台词，珍娜，你肯定也在场。参与了这场讨论。对。对。我甚至不知道每个人参与了多少。
I feel like, yeah, my memories that John took the script, went to a hotel room and rewrote the script. And I want to say the bed bug thing wasn't, was the bed bug thing in the initial script, Angela? I don't think it was. It wasn't the shooting. I think it was because he needs Dwight to come in. That idea that he gets Dwight to run interference was in the original script. I know that. I knew Dwight was, yes. I knew that Dwight ran interference.
我觉得，是的，我的记忆是约翰拿着剧本，去了一个酒店房间，然后重写了剧本。我想说的是，臭虫的事在最初的剧本里没有吧，安吉拉，臭虫的事在最初剧本里有吗？我觉得没有。拍摄初稿里没有。我想这是因为他需要让德怀特出场。他让德怀特来干扰（他们）这个想法原本就在剧本里。我知道这个。我知道德怀特会——对。我知道德怀特会去搞破坏。
But specifically the smug bed bug, I'm not sure. No, and that was, yeah, I remember, I have a very distinct memory of that moment, the smug bed bug, because that was an improv, I believe. And my memory is that I remember thinking, wow, this just went a little off the rails. I feel like they're not gonna know what to do with me now because they've established that I'm so crazy
但具体到那个自鸣得意的臭虫，我不太确定。没有，那是，对，我记得，我对那一刻有着非常清晰的记忆，那个自鸣得意的臭虫，因为那是一个即兴表演，我相信是这样的。我的记忆是，我当时想，哇，这（剧情）有点失控了。我觉得他们现在不知道该拿我怎么办了，因为他们已经把我塑造成了一个如此疯狂的人
and the story line just got so crazy that unless they wanted to devote a whole bunch of time in the back half of the season to dealing with it, I wonder what they're gonna do with me. Well, the shooting draft, the narration that sets up each scene has zero wording in any way that Jim takes Kathy serious and is attracted to her.
以至于这条故事线变得太疯狂了，除非他们想在这一季的后半部分花大量时间来处理这件事，否则我在想他们会拿我怎么办。好吧，拍摄初稿里，每场戏开头的旁白没有任何字眼表明吉姆把凯西当回事并且被她吸引。
Like at all, not once. It's like Kathy is enamored with him, but Jim doesn't like think there's any threat. And there's the scene of a phone call and I copy and pasted it so I brought it in. The phone call that Jim and Pam have, Pam says, is she still there? And Jim says, yep.
一点也没有，一次也没有。这就好比凯西对她迷恋不已，但吉姆根本不觉得有什么威胁。这里有一个打电话的场景，我复制粘贴了过来，所以我把它带来了。吉姆和潘打的那个电话，潘说，她还在那儿吗？吉姆说，对。
And then Pam says, she's obviously lying about the heat. And Jim goes, of course. And then Pam goes, aw, poor girl, really pathetic. And Jim says, yeah, it is. Pam goes on to say, well, I feel bad for her. I wish I could see your face. You're adorable when you're embarrassed. And Jim goes, yeah, it is. Pam goes on to say, well, I feel bad for her. I wish I could see your face. You're adorable when you're embarrassed. And Jim goes, ha ha.
然后潘说，她对（空调）暖气的事显然是在撒谎。吉姆说，当然。然后潘说，噢，可怜的女孩，真可悲。吉姆说，对，确实是。潘接着说，嗯，我为她感到难过。我真想看看你的脸。你尴尬的时候太可爱了。然后吉姆说，哈哈。
Pam goes, okay, love you. Have fun with that. And Jim says, love you too. I will not. Then Jim hangs up the phone and Kathy says, fun to hear her voice. Scranton feels like a million miles away, right? And it says, Jim looks at Kathy with amused compassion.
潘说，好吧，爱你。玩得开心点。吉姆说，我也爱你。我才不呢。然后吉姆挂了电话，凯西说，听到她的声音真有意思。斯克兰顿感觉就像远在百万英里之外，对吧？上面写着，吉姆带着 amused（ amused 这里应译为：带有一丝 amused 的同情）的同情看着凯西。
So I remember this whole phone call thing, because as a producer, when we were talking about this storyline of this woman being in his hotel room, and Dwight seeing her in a towel or in her little outfit or whatever it was gonna be, I said, the thing for me that I don't want for the Jim and Pam relationship is some secret between Jim and Pam. Like, I want their relationship to be secure enough that like, I don't want people to wonder
所以我记得整个打电话的环节，因为作为制片人，当我们讨论这个女人待在他酒店房间的故事线时，德怀特看到她穿着浴袍或穿着她的小衣服或者无论那会是什么的时候，我当时说，对我而言，我不希望吉姆和潘的关系之间出现某种吉姆和潘之间的秘密。比如，我希望他们的关系足够稳固，以至于我不想让观众去猜
if Jim told her what happened with Kathy. Right. Yes. Yeah, well that's like how my husband and I are. Yes. That's what we would in that scenario, you know, like we talk about stuff like that all the time. That was my pitch.
吉姆有没有告诉她跟凯西发生了什么。对。没错。是的，嗯，这就好像我和我丈夫的关系一样。没错。那就是我们在那种情况下会做的事，你知道的，就像我们会一直谈论这种事一样。那是我的提案。
I was like, I want everyone to hear that Pam is totally secure with Jim being in this room with this woman. And so that dialogue that you just read, Angela, that was my pitch in the room, that we would. And I remember talking to Warren and Halstead about it and saying, like, this is how we're gonna make sure that people know that like Pam and Jim are okay.
我当时就说，我希望每个人都听到潘对吉姆和这个女人共处一室完全感到放心。所以安吉拉你刚才读的那段对话，那就是我在会议上的提案，我们会……我记得跟沃伦和霍尔斯特德谈过这件事，并说，嘿，这就是我们要确保人们知道潘和吉姆好得很的方式。
Right. Yes, yeah. I just remember, I remember it being just the episode being much wackier than it initially was going to be. Yeah. Like it ended up taking a turn that was so wacky that I remember at the time thinking, I wonder if they're gonna know what to do with me after this because it was so cuckoo. Well, another episode I wanna ask you about before I forget is Tallahassee. That's the episode where Catherine Tate
对。是的，没错。我只记得，我记得这一集比最初计划的要古怪得多。对。结果走向变得如此古怪，以至于我记得当时在想，我不知道他们在拍完这个之后是否还知道该拿我怎么办，因为它太疯狂了。好吧，在我忘记之前，我想问你的另一集是《塔拉哈西》。那是凯瑟琳·泰特
has her big conference room moment. I love her monologue in that episode. What was it like to sit and watch her? Like, was that the coolest? She is so cool. I don't know how much, you guys worked together in the second half of the season. She is, first of all, so warm,
在会议室里有高光时刻的那一集。我喜欢她在那一集里的独白。坐在那里看她演戏是什么感觉？那种感觉是不是最酷的？她太酷了。我不知道，你们在这一季后半段合作了多少。她首先是非常热情，
like one of the warmest, nicest people you could ever wanna meet. And she just has such unique rhythms. There's nobody exactly like her. She just has such unique rhythms. There's nobody exactly like her. So it was just really fun, especially to see somebody come in kind of so fully formed, which she did, and then just to watch her play,
可以说是你能遇到的最热情、最友善的人之一。而且她有着非常独特的节奏。没有人能完全取代她。她就是有着如此独特的节奏。没有人能完全取代她。所以这真的很有趣，尤其是看到一个人带着如此成熟的形象出场——她确实做到了——然后看着她飙戏，
especially because I don't think people in the US, for the most part, had been that exposed to her work. And so it was so fun watching somebody just come in and just be so, just bam on camera. Yeah. She just owned the room. We got a question from Isabella H. in Aptos, who said, what are some fun behind the scenes memories that you have from filming The Office?
尤其是因为我觉得美国观众大部分对她的作品并不是很了解。所以看着一个人出场，然后就那么……在镜头前光芒四射，真的太有趣了。对。她完全掌控了全场。我们收到了来自阿普托斯的伊莎贝拉·H.的一个问题，她问，你在拍摄《办公室》时有什么有趣的幕后回忆吗？
Do you have any? Did you like our food? So I have a very specific memory of the breakfast orders and that there was Rashida style, which I want to say was egg whites with like tortillas. There was definitely a tortilla. But I remember always being like, the eggs are really oily and they're like, oh, you have to order it Jenna style.
你有什么吗？你喜欢我们的食物吗？所以关于早餐订单我有一个非常具体的记忆，那就是有“拉什达风格”，我想说的是蛋清加类似玉米饼的东西。里面绝对有玉米饼。但我记得我总是说，这些鸡蛋真的很油，然后他们就会说，哦，你得点“珍娜风格”。
And Jenna style was, they weren't allowed to just like, squirt a bunch of oil into the pan to scramble the eggs are really oily and they're like oh you have to order it Jenna style and Jenna style was they weren't allowed to just like squirt a bunch of oil into the pan to scramble the eggs I don't know if they scrambled it in something different but I know that if you wanted it not. Jenna style was butter no oil. Yes Jenna style was butter no oil so I used to get like the egg taco whatever I would call it Rashida, but then I would get Jenna style, which meant no oil for me, just butter. And the crafty was great because I would come in at 5 a.m. and I'd be there till like 7 p.m. So I had my foods that I would eat. I was doing a bunch of small meals. So I would
而“珍娜风格”是，他们不允许只是往平底锅里倒一大堆油来炒鸡蛋……鸡蛋真的很油，然后他们就会说，哦，你得点“珍娜风格”，而“珍娜风格”是，他们不允许只是往平底锅里倒一大堆油来炒鸡蛋，我不知道他们是不是用别的东西炒的，但我知道如果你不想……“珍娜风格”就是黄油不要油。对，“珍娜风格”就是黄油不要油，所以我过去常点类似鸡蛋塔可之类的东西，无论我怎么叫它，拉什达，但接着我会点“珍娜风格”，这意味着对我来说不要油，只要黄油。而且后勤补给站（Crafty）真的很棒，因为我早上5点到，一直待到晚上7点左右。所以我会有我要吃的食物。我在吃一堆小份的餐食。所以我就会
do my Siggy's yogurt and you guys always had really good berries. And then you always had perfect bananas and I would have a banana and almond butter. And I had like my very specific meals that I would have at certain times. And you had a good espresso machine. Yeah. That espresso machine was really good. We did.
吃我的西吉斯（Siggy's）酸奶，而且你们总是准备很好的浆果。然后你们总是有完美的香蕉，我会吃一根香蕉和杏仁酱。我有一些非常特定的食物，要在特定时间吃。而且你们有一台很好的浓缩咖啡机。对。那台浓缩咖啡机真的很好。我们确实有。
Yeah, I had very specific, but the food. My memory though is always that at hot snack was 10.30 in the morning, and it would be like shrimp scampi. Something so weird at 10.30 in the morning and it would be like shrimp scampi. Something so weird at 1030 in the morning. But you know, if you got to work at 515 in the morning, you are starving by 1015. You're not gonna make it to lunch.
对，我有非常特定的饮食习惯，但是食物。不过我的记忆总是，热心零食时间是早上10点30分，然后就会是像鲜虾意面这样的东西。早上10点30分吃这么古怪的东西，而且会是像鲜虾意面。早上10点30分吃这么古怪的东西。但是你知道的，如果你早上5点15分上班，到10点15分你就会饿得要命。你撑不到吃午饭的。
To this day, my body, like it hits 1030 and I'm like, are we having a meal? Like, what's our meal? Well, Lindsay, something that I know happened at the end of your run, you kind of mentioned this. You said you wouldn't find out if you were coming back the next week until the Friday before. Well, on your last episode, you rapped, and then you didn't come back. Yeah.
直到今天，我的身体，一到10点30分我就觉得，我们是要吃一顿吗？我们的饭是什么？好吧，林赛，我知道在你的戏份快结束时发生了一件事，你刚才也提到了。你说直到前一周的周五，你才知道自己下周是否还会回来。好吧，在你拍的最后一集里，你即兴说唱了，然后你就没再回来。对。
And you did not get the big send-off. Yeah. So I want to give it to you today. Thank you. All right everyone gather around. Gather around. Gather around. That is an episode and series wrap for Lindsay Broad. Let's give her a big applause for playing Kathy. Yay. Thanks guys. You're welcome. You know what we had a lot of people write in with love for you and what you brought to the role. Natalie M. from Kingwood, Texas says, please tell Lindsay that we love her and we see her
而且你没有得到盛大的欢送。对。所以今天我想把它补给你。谢谢。好了，大家聚过来。聚过来。聚过来。这是林赛·布罗德在剧中的最后一集兼全剧杀青。让我们为她扮演凯西报以热烈的掌声。耶。谢谢大家。不客气。你知道吗，有很多人写信表达对你的喜爱以及你为这个角色带来的东西。来自得克萨斯州金伍德的娜塔莉·M.说，请告诉林赛我们爱她，我们也看到了她
struggles for playing a character that comes between Jim and Pam. It's definitely not easy to play a part so well that brings people to believe you are that character, especially when the character can be a little on the evil side, ha ha. But she is a beautiful, loving lady who is definitely seen by the non-crazy side of the fandom. Oh, that's so sweet. Well, thank you guys. And if you guys, if anybody wants to see what I look like now, I am
作为一个夹在吉姆和潘之间的角色的扮演者所经历的挣扎。要把一个让人们深信你就是那个角色的部分演得这么好，绝对不是一件容易的事，尤其是当这个角色可能有点偏向邪恶的时候，哈哈。但她是一个美丽、充满爱心的女士，粉丝群体中没有疯狂的那一部分人绝对是看在眼里的。哦，这太甜了。好吧，谢谢你们。如果你们——如果有人想看看我现在的样子，我
I'm on Instagram at Lindsey Broad. That's probably where you can find me. Yeah, we'll link to it. Send me hate mail. No, we are going to share in our stories. And Lindsay, we just want to end the interview with something we do with our guests. It's the call sheet questions. Number one, what was your first job in entertainment? The pilot of Gossip Girl.
我的Instagram账号是林赛·布罗德（Lindsey Broad）。你们大概可以在那儿找到我。对，我们会放上链接。给我发恨意邮件吧。不，我们会在我们的快拍（Stories）里分享。林赛，我们想用一个我们对嘉宾常用的环节来结束这次采访。那就是通告单（Call Sheet）快问快答。第一题，你在娱乐圈的第一份工作是什么？《绯闻女孩》的试播集。
Oh! entertainment? The pilot of Gossip Girl. The first scene of the pilot of Gossip Girl. I am Melanie 91 who is following Serena around Grand Central Station with my phone. That's how I got my SAG card. Oh that's so good. Wow. Yeah it's a good one. Oh I'm gonna go look for it. My daughter just started watching Gossip Girl so we'll have to go look for it. Actually the thing that Netflix has up as like the preview is me following her around. So people like keep texting me about that. Oh, so fun. All right, question number two.
哦！娱乐圈的第一份工作？《绯闻女孩》的试播集。《绯闻女孩》试播集的第一场戏。我是梅兰妮91号，拿着手机在中央车站跟着瑟琳娜。我就是这样拿到演员工会卡（SAG card）的。哦，太棒了。哇。对，这是一个很好的经历。哦，我要去找来看看。我女儿刚开始看《绯闻女孩》，所以我们得去找来看看。事实上，Netflix上作为预览播放的那个片段就是我跟着她到处跑。所以人们一直在给我发短信聊这个。哦，太有趣了。好的，第二题。
Do you speak any other languages? No. Do you play a musical instrument? I played the trumpet in middle school and high school because that's what my parents had in their attic. I played a cornet, which was a miniature trumpet. Can you still play that? I probably could, I could definitely play the scales.
你会说其他语言吗？不会。你会弹奏乐器吗？我在初中和高中时吹过小号因为那是我的父母在阁楼里留下的东西。我吹的是短号，也就是一种迷你小号。你现在还会吹吗？我可能还会，我绝对能吹出音阶。
Yeah. All right, what is a place that you've been to that you absolutely loved? New Orleans. I spent two months there filming 21 Jump Street and other than New York City, it's probably my favorite place on the planet. Yeah, I love New Orleans.
对。好的，你去过哪个让你绝对爱不释手的地方？新奥尔良。我在那里花了两个月拍摄《龙虎少年队》，除了纽约市，它可能是我星球上最喜欢的地方。对，我爱新奥尔良。
Such a great town. All right, what do you like to do on the weekends? We do a family movie night in our backyard and we have a screen and we have a projector and about once a month when the weather's good, we invite a bunch of families over and we just put it up online. This is what we're showing and everybody brings their blankets, we invite a bunch of families over and we just put it up online. This is what we're showing,
真是一个好地方。好的，你周末喜欢做什么？我们在后院办家庭电影之夜，我们有一个幕布，我们有一个投影仪，大约一个月一次，天气好的时候，我们邀请一堆家庭过来，然后我们把它发到网上。这就是我们要播放的节目，每个人都带上毯子，我们邀请一堆家庭过来，然后我们把它发到网上。这就是我们要播放的节目，
and everybody brings their blankets, and we have a popcorn machine, and then you have to bring a bag of candy to share. That is so fun. What is the last movie you guys did? The last movie we did, we closed the season with Home Alone in November, and we're reopening the season,
每个人都带上毯子，我们有一台爆米花机，然后你必须带一包糖果来分享。这太有趣了。你们最近看的一部电影是什么？我们看的上一部电影，我们在11月以《小鬼当家》结束了这一季（指露天电影季），我们要重新开启这一季，
I believe, with Willy Wonka, the original. We show 80s and 90s movies, because it's good for the kids' attention spans to watch the slower paced movies. Yeah. So we'll open it again in March. I do love that you say this season's going to start. It's going to start.
我想，放映的是原版的《查理和巧克力工厂》。我们放映80年代和90年代的电影，因为看节奏较慢的电影对孩子们的注意力跨度有好处。对。所以我们会在3月份再次开始。我确实很喜欢你说“这一季要开始了”。它要开始了。
Yes. We do it once a month. I love it. Lastly, what is your favorite midnight snack? So Costco has these chocolate covered strawberries in the freezer section. Wait, wait, wait. Is it called true fruit?
对。我们一个月办一次。我太喜欢了。最后，你最喜欢的午夜零食是什么？Costco冷冻区有那种巧克力草莓。等等，等等，等等。是不是叫真水果（True Fruit）？
Yes. True fruit. True fruit. And the thing about true fruit is that the chocolate on true fruit is like the best chocolate I've ever had. It's so good, Lindsay. I have never had this.
对。真水果。真水果。关于真水果（True Fruit）厉害的地方在于，真水果上面的巧克力简直是我吃过的最棒的巧克力。太好吃了，林赛。我从来没吃过这个。
Angela. I eat half a bag of it just walking around. I go to Costco on Monday nights when my kids are at their little play practice and I will eat like half a bag of them just walking around Costco. So now I have to take a break. Do you ever do the raspberries? Because I really like the chocolate covered raspberries and then- They only sell them at Target, right?
安吉拉。我一边走一边能吃掉半袋。我每周一晚上趁孩子们上小排练时去Costco，我会在逛Costco的同时吃掉大概半袋。所以我现在得克制一下。你吃过覆盆子口味的吗？因为我真的很喜欢巧克力覆盆子，然后——它们只在Target出售，对吧？
I think- Is that what it is? Costco has and True Fruit just recently I saw also makes like a dried fruit so it's not frozen. But their chocolate is so good. And it's like part white chocolate and part milk chocolate. Angela. Okay. I mean, you fruit and chocolate.
我想——是这样的吗？Costco有卖，而且我最近看到True Fruit也出了那种果干，所以不是冷冻的。但它们的巧克力太好吃了。而且它一部分是白巧克力，一部分是牛奶巧克力。安吉拉。好吧。我的意思是，水果加巧克力。
I'm in, I'm in. It's so good. It's specific though. It's like the brand is. Yep. It's true. Yeah. Well, Lindsay, this was so good. It's specific though. It's like the brand is. Yep, it's true. Yeah. Well, Lindsay, this was so wonderful.
我入坑了，我入坑了。太好吃了。不过挺有特色的。就像是这个品牌。没错。确实如此。好吧，林赛，这真是太棒了。不过挺有特色的。就像是这个品牌。没错，确实如此。好吧，林赛，这真是太美妙了。
And we are gonna share with folks how they can find you on Instagram. And thank you so much for being part of Office Ladies. We just have enjoyed this so much. Yeah, I hope I run into you ladies soon again. I'm gonna be out in New York in May and I'm gonna hit you up. I wanna go see, Let's see a show.
我们将向大家分享如何在Instagram上找到你。非常感谢你来参加《办公室女士》。我们真的非常享受这一切。对，我希望我很快能再碰见你们这些女士。我5月份要去纽约，到时候我会联系你们。我想去看——去看一场演出。
You want to see Glengarry Glen Ross with me? Yeah. Right. With Bob Odenkirk. Yes. OK. Message me. I know. Jen and I ran into each other. This is a funny story. I saw Jenna. I was seeing a play with a friend in the city and I see Jenna come in. And I said to my friend, I was like, I think that's Jenna.
你想跟我一起去看《大亨游戏》（Glengarry Glen Ross）吗？对。没错。鲍勃·奥登科克演的。对。OK。给我发信息。我知道。珍娜和我偶遇了。这是一个有趣的故事。我看到珍娜了。我和一个朋友在城里看话剧，我看到珍娜进来了。我对我的朋友说，我当时想，那好像是珍娜。
And we had been talking about doing- Office ladies. About me coming on office ladies. Yeah. And I was like, I can't stalk this poor woman. Like she's probably just used to people coming up to her in the lobby and I'm just going to like make her anxiety. It's like I was going to just like give you that like nervous system spike. But then I was like, Jenna and then luckily, thank God, you were like Lindsay.
我们之前一直在谈论做——办公室女士。关于我上《办公室女士》的事。对。然后我想，我不能去跟踪这个可怜的女人。她可能已经习惯了别人在门厅里找她搭话，而我只会让她的焦虑加剧。就好像我打算给你的神经系统来一下猛烈刺激。但后来我想，珍娜——然后幸运的是，谢天谢地，你喊了“林赛”。
And I was like, oh my God. Thank God. But we had a cute run-in. I am kicking myself that we didn't get a photo together. Like why did Pam and Kathy not snap a photo together when we saw each other? I know, well in May. We'll do it in May.
然后我说，哦，天哪。谢天谢地。但我们偶遇得很可爱。我到现在还在懊恼我们没有一起拍张合影。为什么潘和凯西见面时没有一起拍张合影呢？我知道，嗯，5月份。我们在5月份拍。
We'll do it in May. And then maybe I'll see you. I think I'm gonna do the office fan convention this year. So if you're going, I'll see you. I would love to see you at that. That would be fun. We'll get dinner this time. Yes, let's. Ladies, what fun. Yes, I'll see you. I would love to see you at that. That would be fun. We'll get dinner this time. Yes, let's.
我们在5月份拍。然后也许我会见到你。我想我今年要参加办公室粉丝见面会。所以如果你去的话，我会见到你的。我很乐意在那里见到你。那会很有趣的。这次我们要一起吃晚饭。好的，一言为定。女士们，多有趣啊。对，我会见到你。我很乐意在那里见到你。那会很有趣的。这次我们要一起吃晚饭。好的，一言为定。
Ladies, what fun. Yes, thank you so much. Thank you, guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey, and is produced by Jenna F Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
女士们，多开心啊。好的，非常感谢。谢谢你们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audacy的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。Audacy的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。